on soit avec eon emile on imagine sous
le choc après l'assassinât de son
président appui sous le choc comme de
bien entendu encore encore une fois on
va on va entendre malheureusement les
mêmes l'ancien à savoir à chaque
événement dramatique et bas une va
naître un espoir venez on espère que
c'est un cil des points de départ d'un
nouveau changement
et puis tu il vient pas en tout cas la
première chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que évidemment c'est cet
assassinat est un crime qui doit être
condamné sans réserve
cela dit joël moïse est victime de sa
propre politique et de 7 et de sa
manière de diriger le pays
quand un président dirige par décret et
en moins de 500 change cette fois de
premier ministre c'est qu'il ya un
problème de fond il a voulu se maintenir
mal depuis que les manifestations
il n'avait aucune maîtrise sur la
sécurité du pays sur les gangs qui
fonctionnait jusqu'à ce dernier jusqu'à
la semaine dernière on a enregistré les
cas de quinze personnes ont été
assassinées
les gangs font régner leur pouvoir sur
toro quoi c'est pratiquement sûr tout le
pays
voilà aujourd'hui joseph joël moïse paye
les shoes n'y a pas à s'en réjouir comme
bien entendu
alors pour moi ça soulève une bonne
question à qui profite le crime
à qui profite le crime et derrière cette
grande distance y en a trois autres à
savoir qui est le commanditaire ou quels
sont les commanditaires de ces crimes
deuxièmement elles vont être les
conséquences
on ne connaît pas troisièmement est ce
que la collectivité internationale va
continuer à fermer les lieux
hu a gardé une attitude d'indifférence
telle qu'elle l'a fait jusqu'à prise
alors justement on va essayer de prendre
ces trois questions dans rentrer dans le
bon sens tout d'abord sur à qui profite
le crime
on a appris ce soir en tout cas par la
bouche de l'ambassadeur haïtien aux
états unis qu'il semblerait que les
assassins soient des mercenaires
professionnels
on imagine qu'un beaucoup de mobiles
puisque beaucoup de monde ne les met pas
en haïti mais est ce qu'on peut avoir
une idée peut-être plus précise les
observateurs aguerris d'haïti ont une
idée peut-être plus précise de
l'identité de ce commando où on est dans
le flou absolu ça peut être finalement
n'importe qui on en est au stade des
conjectures le fait le fait que ce soit
des mercenaires ça me paraît tout à fait
possible dans la mesure où ça s'est déjà
produit en haïti et par 1958 un groupe
d'officiels siens s'étaient rebellés
contre duvalier
venant de miami et il était arrivé avec
des mercenaires donc l'assaut s'est déjà
produite
donc c'est possible at il été assassiné
est ce que le de la question est ce ce
n'est pas forcément partie métier même
quels sont les commanditaires de ce
commando qui agissent après qu'elles
s'appliquent à tresser rémunérés pour le
faire
sur les réactions lieu se dit choquée
préoccupée par le risque d'une spirale
de la violence bailon joe biden
américain réagit lui aussi il ya une
réunion au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
qui est prévue demain le monde semble
découvrir les problèmes d'haïti
ce soir elles sont blondes les cours ont
comme ce qu'on voyait nous la première
fois que la première fois et des mois
que sadi était la stabilité que
l'insécurité dieu en haïti on le sait je
savais qu au moins depuis le début de
l'année pour le faire alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait bien sûr je suis très sévère
avec la communauté internationale bien
entendu avec les haïtiens au site et les
hommes politiques haïtiens ils n'ont
fait que tu te laisses qui corrompent
une tape sur tout ne pas vouloir
s'entendre ya une question simple
négatif après dix neuf mille isles la
semaine dernière a été lui même qui se
verrait louise a nommé un nouveau
premier ministre
le premier ministre actuellement en
place qui a annoncé ce n'est pas ma
l'assassinât du président et se dit les
affaires courantes alors exclusive à
continuer ou le premier ministre qui a
été nommé qui va prendre les rênes du
pouvoir
magicka position à prendre sur la
question mais voilà cette voie là il fit
abattre hautement hilton de discorde
déjà dans les milieux politiques
haïtiens l'insécurité on sait gré d'un
le pays
désormais cet assassinat cette absence
plongent le pays haïti
dans encore plus d'inconnues si c'est
possible c'est même carrément maintenant
qui va succéder qui va succéder et dans
quelles conditions les élections vont
devoir avoir lieu mais que va-t-il se
passer si j'étais lui je vous rappelle
quand même que j'ai dit à moïse a été
juste une base électorale des dizaines
une participation de 10% de l'électorat
et que je faisais louis le petit lac à
qui les fait pas tout blanc dans la
sphère une fois plus soit parce que il
était quand même soupçonner des
corrections de la faire se trouvent des
échos qu'arrivé au coeur voyez encore
une fois je tiens je vais bien je veux
pas que ma famille n'est pas fait je ne
rêvais pas du tout la mort de cet homme
ce n'est pas un bon moment deux
manifestations réunissant ce n'est tout
simplement ils ne sont pas non plus des
plus grandes victimes at il dit il vient
d'être détruit merci en tout cas jacques
ayant émis le président de l'association
ecti mémoires et cultures d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france ce
soir